i'm very happy to be back in hollywood
i'm not only a person but
where
my mother used to say
you read what you saw
i should
listen to my mom last year
i was
complained about mispronouncing my name
in publicly
and i'm so sorry
because i've looked at the nominees of
the
incredible
in this category and then now i have to
pronounce
please forgive me
in advance
well
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a
supporting role
kieran hines belfast
troy cutter hoda
the power of the dog
j.k simmons being the red cardos
cody smith mcphee the power of the dog
[Applause]
and
the oscar goes to
no not me nadi
oh my god
this is the first oscar and nomination
for troy kotzer he is the second deaf
actor to win
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is amazing to be here on this
journey
i cannot believe i'm here
thank you so much to all the members of
the academy for recognizing my work
it's really amazing that our film coda
has reached out worldwide it even
reached all the way to the white house
and they invited the cast to coda to
visit and have a tour of the white house
and we met our president joe and dr jill
and i was planning on teaching them some
dirty sign language but marley matlin
told me to behave myself so
don't worry marley i won't drop any
f-bombs in my speech today
instead i really want to thank all of
the wonderful deaf theater stages where
i was allowed and given the opportunity
to develop my craft as an actor
thank you
i read one of spielberg's books recently
and he said that
the best director
the definition of the best director was
a skilled communicator sean hader you
are the best communicator
and the reason why is you brought the
deaf world and the hearing world
together and you are our bridge
and your name will forever be on that
bridge sean hader bridge here in
hollywood and that was
supported by apple sundance all of our
cast our crew our producers
and the community of gloucester
massachusetts so i just want to say hey
fishermen hey popeyes don't forget to
eat your spinach
my dad
he was the best signer
in our family
but he was in a car accident
and he became paralyzed from the neck
down
and he no longer was able to sign
dad
i learned so much from you
i'll always love you
you are my hero
thank you
for thank you to my biggest fans my wife
and my daughter kira in my hometown of
mesa arizona
and mark finley my manager and our team
i just wanted to say that
this is dedicated to the deaf community
the coda community and the disabled
community this is our moment
[Applause]
to my mom
my dad and my brother mark they're not
here today but look at me now i did it
i love you
thank you
[Applause]
you